l'inquiétude des enseignants à la suite
du phénomène mondial pokémon les
échanges de ces petits personnages venus
du japon très prisé par les bambins se
monnaient désormais dans les cours de
récréation l'exemple dans l'eure avec ce
reportage de virginie du croquer et
pierre basque et la folie pokémon dans
les cours de récréation des dizaines
d'enfants agglutinés autour de dizaines
de cartes depuis noël
après le japon et les etats unis les
monstres de poche s'attaque à la france
mais le principal du collège jean jaurès
à evreux a décidé de freiner l'évasion
les changes ou le troc ne suffisait plus
aux enfants pour augmenter leur
collection l'argent entrait dans le
collège de mesures ont été prises
aujourd'hui il est interdit de venir
avec toute sa collection et de vendre
des cartes dans la cour les échanges de
cartes quelque chose qu'on a toujours
connu dans toutes les cours de
récréation ça ne pose pas de problème ce
qui qu'a commencé à nous poser des
problèmes c'est le moment où on a
découvert que des cartes étaient vendus
et que les sommes qui étaient demandés
pour un certain nombre de ces cartes
étaient des sommes exorbitantes puisque
on a la certitude qu'une carte a été
vendu 100 francs le problème a été réglé
avec les familles et il se dit je crois
qu'ils en font en dit tout à l'heure que
certaines auraient pu se vendre 200
francs dans le commerce les petites
bêtes s'achète 25 francs les 11 ou 75
francs les 60 soit de francs l'unité
dans un paquet il y a une ou deux cartes
rares les plus convoités celle qui
s'achète à la pièce beaucoup plus cher
certains enfants jusqu'à 6 ans carte
écartera qu'on en double c'est bien les
banques comme ça on peut s'acheter plein
de paquets et à paris sur ce que ça se
vend cher voilà mais bon personne
n'achète 200 francs ça tourne autour de
80 si on va la rendre
mais dès qu'on les a tout bon bah on
s'arrête quand on arrête d'acheter
jusqu'à jusqu'à ce que la prochaine
mission
en cinquième un enfant sur trois époques
et maniaque tout l'argent de poche y
passe les pokémon c'est un vrai business